gang let's talk about that middle class
famous tour baby coming to a town near
you the hottest thing on the road right
now we've been zipping all over the
country and we're coming to a town near
you kippy straighten them out first of
all we got a second show out in chicago
sold the first one out yes we did zany's
still some tickets left for the late
show then we're over there in rosemont
tickets are moving for that so get them
goddamn
then we're also going to be in
pittsburgh buffalo and detroit get them
now before they're gone yeah stand-up
show we play ayg with the crowd you've
seen the clips what are we doing come
see us bring the homies bring the bozos
bring the squad do it welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is r u garbage there is a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians we
find that the group to be classy if
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash i'm your host dave trolley coming
at you on a beautiful day down here in
antony's basement the smell of spring is
in the air uh-huh and also a little bit
of pee dog coming out of her room what's
pee dawg she's up there getting wet i
think wait what a little mouth
woody what's pee dawg sure man
he's up there getting loose he dog
[Laughter]
angel dust [ __ ]
i'm talking about the good [ __ ] i
thought you meant she was up there
getting railed into this sundress or
something that's what you like
know i don't know it smells like burning
wire coming out of her room i don't know
what she's into ketamine but i know it
ain't kind bud i can tell you that my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table as you know it's a family episode
right baby just uncle hank kippy t-bone
the homies and the bozos
just the fam kevin james ryan ladies and
gentlemen hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube as you
[Applause]
and then obviously the greatest website
oh that wasn't it i like that that was a
new true to rooney really hit the high
note red bull hit you right you were
like stephen tyler over there
i look over he's
he's got a scarf on his microphone
[Laughter]
guys patreon.com the greatest goddamn
website ever invented shout out to al
gore for inventing the internet
appreciate that [ __ ]
uh you sign up you get bonus episodes
ayg episodes are hard feeling every week
which
are pretty [ __ ] bonkers uh you gotta
check those out for sure everybody relax
we're joking having a good time it's all
scripted
um
and then we do live streams every month
with our top top two tiers uh there's
[ __ ]
so much [ __ ] on there there's our we did
cribs of our childhood homes we grew up
in we have
videos of us going to the shore like 10.
disney coming up and we got the ten
thousand dollar bet disney's let's cut
the [ __ ] it's all the tomahawk steak
disney's in the box what about the
appetizers we're doing the ten thousand
dollar bet next week gonna [ __ ]
myself wonder if we don't have it if we
just show them like the home screen of
patreon and be like listen we're good
for it
i'm just not liquid right now these
koozies are just as good as money
because if you need goods he's wearing
about 15 grand and i'm laying around
we're gonna do your hands freezing
holding a drink huh
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good give it up for
t-bone mcscruffin's toby mcbuttons
what's up dudes yeah if there's any
podcasts out there looking for a new
producer i'm going to need a job in
about a week once we [ __ ] spin that
route wheel dude
wait till the hard feelings if that
thing loses i karumba
i'm gonna deny the whole thing you
thought last week between me and the big
men were bad it's gonna be rough
uh speaking of patreon i wanted to bring
something up as i
told you on that uh hard feelings
episode told me a lot of things on that
feelings episode
yeah jesus christ
mostly that i'm a bad human being but if
you don't know i got caught
[ __ ] i got violated in a [ __ ] hotel
room by a [ __ ] cleaning person
someone playing with your b-dogs
it's fun it's like an hour before
checkout i'm [ __ ] getting ready in
the bathroom and this [ __ ] guy walks
into my [ __ ] room i'm standing there
buck naked i got my [ __ ] leg up on
the sink a hair dryer halfway up my
[ __ ] and he's [ __ ] sneaking a peek
at my [ __ ] goodie bag uh but i
discovered something in that hotel you
tell me if you think this is classy or
not homeless i've never done this but
i've been doing it ever since uh i was
at that hotel okay you ever take a hand
towel and just leave it on the edge of
the sink it's nice to operate it's nice
it's dude there's no backsplash like
fine dining [ __ ] doesn't get on your
[ __ ] shirt you don't got toothpaste
all over you
it's a real nice trick just regular hand
towel in the house sacrifice it put it
in front of the sink i started doing it
at the house those hand towels in hotels
are tough for me
i use them for everything that's why
that's why it's tough for me to use them
i know what i've used them for and then
to go dry off with it it's a it's a
tough look
he's not talking about doing the windows
so it's like uh it's a little i'm a germ
guy i'm in my head a lot and it's like
you know
are they doing cold washes they don't
know what just what are they doing over
there that they'd shut down are you
kidding me who knows you think they're
putting those things on the gentle cycle
no no no they're doing that at a
they should be new ones crematorium
[ __ ] time but i stole the two uh they
start they put makeup bragging stones
the makeup or the past two plays we had
the makeup right there were darker
colors
maybe that's what the charges were on
the mx oh yeah yeah i got knocked for
550. counting the [ __ ] makeup bags
so that's in your blood to steal [ __ ]
from a hotel man well i don't mind can't
shake that your mom will take anything
not bolted down
what they want you to take the remotes
they're barely they're begging you to
take them mom whose phone books are
these
uh how many bibles do you need the
ladies use them now a lot those makeup
things are hot yeah they clean off yeah
they all they're not separate they're
colored so they don't stain up yeah so i
yanked a couple of them that was the
present that i brought back the big
thing on the road why i hit the gift
shop you know what i mean
my place did not have a gift shop
you buy meth out front if you wanted um
the big thing uh on this trip was the
one hotel we stayed in phoenix had the
had a bluetooth enabled
mirror in the bathroom i told you i
don't like those mirrors it's too
intense that i told you i don't i
especially i don't need that thing
peeking on me if it's got bluetooth
[ __ ]
if it's got bluetooth capabilities who
knows there's a little cam in there i
feel like briscoe's on the other side of
that thing exactly waiting for me to
crack
you just hear a knock on it that's how
it comes in step forward
where's your ball sack i'm like i don't
know it's [ __ ] i was in the pool what
do you want from me sir put your penis
back on stop me man i saw that thing i
hooked up too sweet cranked it gave him
a show i cried i cranked it too it's
real loud man i left my bathing suit
i wasn't yeah you got to get up pretty
early and i got a big piece of tape on
the mirror
i got the [ __ ] blue the blue
electrical tape
i'm not catching
man i'm real weird i'll look you know it
looks like there's somebody in there
yeah there's all like dots and not
forget the [ __ ] out of here we don't
need smart mirrors knock that [ __ ] off
they're gonna take over [ __ ] kill us
all
wake up it's over top of you
[Laughter]
the doobie brothers are playing yeah
also that one hotel room which was
trashy at first but i ended up loving it
immediately you guys were complaining
about it at first
though
the tv was on the left-hand side i love
the tv on the side i'm a side guy
fantastic i lay sideways and watch this
and then that way you can turn around at
night and not have the tv blasted on
your face if you want to keep seinfeld
playing cause you got to give them the
views i don't like it at my feet i feel
like i'm in a hospital bed yeah you know
yeah i'm not doing that you had a real
good line at the airbnb in denver where
you're like somebody hit the seinfeld
button
yeah let's get it cooking i tweeted that
did all right
doggy i got a little something something
i wanted to get into we've talked about
it but i finally uh
as you know i was very anti-air friar
for a long time we both were on this
show oh [ __ ] i bought one a couple
months ago never opened it up
i'm telling you
i'm like we're talking about talking at
a bird i'm like what are you gonna do
for dinden
she goes i don't know we could go here
we could go there i was like or i was
like let's make [ __ ] um some steaks
on like the cast iron i like doing that
like the [ __ ] butter you got it
seasoned did you take the time and
season and all that stuff relax okay
just making sure
you're 90s johnny toaster oven
well yeah we always had one of those um
i like doing that that's fun i like that
process and then letting it rest and the
[ __ ] slight i like cut and stuff
you did a spoon with the time in there
yeah what am i i just said that that
yeah
bozo ramsay over here yeah whatever it's
a good time so
i um
so i'm like let's do that she goes let's
try the air fry it's been sitting in the
kitchen in a box in a corner i go all
right we got some steak tips shout out
butcherbox.com
i'm telling you
seven minutes in this [ __ ] thing
it's crazy what's going on in there it
was the best dude it was the best bite
of steak i've ever had in my life well
we didn't coordinate this uh i think a
little montreal [ __ ] seasoning on
there too i hate to admit it we also
purchased one about a month or so i know
we've mentioned you've purchased one and
she's [ __ ] big on it dude you could
put a [ __ ] lizard in there and it's
[ __ ] crispy i don't know i don't know
what's going on it's proper insanity
they need to be bigger though i need
like i need like a pizza oven one you
know what i mean because everything's
got to be separated and stuff like that
yeah you have to stake in there yeah
eventually you two will start listening
when people telling you that things are
good people don't know what's going on
only i do
oh the process is something comes out
you [ __ ] on it you hate it because you
don't know about it and you're scared of
it then you try it once and you [ __ ]
deny you ever [ __ ] discredited it
i always liked an air fryer they're
fantastic mine's light blue i always
admit well i'm wrong i
hated it in the beginning and now it's
fanta it was dude it [ __ ]
it came out i'm like we were sitting in
the kitchen like we didn't even like
played it we were just like eating it
out of the thing because we got so
excited how good it was it was a [ __ ]
good time throwing hanzi a piece hey day
one you know what i mean ponzi's big on
roast beef nowadays that's what we're
training with roast beef
jesus christ dad roast beef
he's a dog what are you getting slices
at the deli yeah you get like a half a
pound i have it pre-sliced yeah yeah
never never roast beef in our house when
i was a kid we got it for the dog ham
and turkey oh yeah i don't know who the
[ __ ] eating what nine-year-olds eating
roast beef sandwiches i knew a couple of
kids that rolled in with them they're no
longer living for sure
they were in a bad way with even worse
people those guys [ __ ] looking for a
trade we had sanctions on those kids uh
yeah no
no we gotta [ __ ] embargo yeah
you got to train with high priority
treats when you want to teach them
something new or that you know did you
give them skittles or something
you see whatever bubble tape
whatever
stuff it's a fam episode
like the big man said so guys when you
know you sign up for patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
just the best way to do it and also
if you're listening as today comes out
come see us at [ __ ] rose monzaney's
[Applause]
yeah this comes out thursday yes
chi-town shy town two sold-out shows
maybe uh and then tonight in rosemont
come see the boys yeah can't wait can't
wait to get back to chicago oh and if
one of them isn't sold out we'll crop
that pick make it look real nice oh i
got my best crop guy on it
i don't know what's going on the lights
in this place
i'm flying in new guy luke just to crop
that real nice
just crash test dummy sitting in the bag
having a good time though
[Laughter]
come out and see us gang can't wait
never been never been a rosemont before
yeah i don't think it's like a i don't
think it's like an anchor city you know
what i mean it's not really drawn a lot
of it's a suburb no it's it's it's an
area by the airport what's the
convention center like huh
they have a football team the rosemont
rollers
that's the football team
they're on rollerblades getting decked
oh no i was thinking they were all in
ecstasy they're just lining up hugging
each other
that you would drug boy huh yeah get
your hands on some people that's what
you like up there with teddy
or [ __ ] [ __ ] gets weird uh
kippy's got a hair on him today a hair
on him you're a little spry in the
spring here a lot of sex talk coming out
of you
okay
kid's all riled up
i like it all right uh this one's from
saint ben 10 homies the trash to go on
ayg live show on a thursday still be
hungover on sunday ouch
baby that's what we're doing at these
shows we're partying yikes yeah
it's a good time couple of casualties on
this trip so we're getting [ __ ] up i
know um but okay
this one
home run of a name if you ask me i'm
partial in this though you know what i
mean
kj something foley lies
[Laughter]
hey
i don't agree with it but you got the
big man that's right
that's a 95 mile an hour fastball right
over the plate give him the heat
he wants the smoke
this is from foley's a fat lying piece
of [ __ ]
no now that's my patreon name
uh let's see 10 homie one time my mom
made me go in and pre-pay three dollars
and change at the gas station when i was
10 because she was too embarrassed
that's a tough that's hard
oh you'll never forget that until the
day you die you'll probably that guy
probably hates paying with anything and
change he probably gets changed and
throws it back at the cashier i remember
my mom doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] driving
drove me crazy just look in there
there's more change in there that and as
i mentioned when the checkbook used to
come out in the [ __ ] grocery store i
used to tear up i thought they were
going to take the house away from us oh
yeah that was bad the check we were
never got cash on you we were never
[ __ ] we were never a big check in the
grocery store but i do remember times
i had like an sat
tutor or like a prep or whatever
this girl i think i've mentioned her
before she was [ __ ] the size of a
house i don't know how she fit in this
tiny little room and she would eat egg
rolls while she was [ __ ]
test prepping me
she
it was [ __ ]
she would hold him like cigarettes it
was [ __ ] crazy i feel like your
parents are trying to cut like tv lawyer
deals we're like yeah we'll give you
half up front and the other half if he
gets into college oh it was real like uh
i can she was like i remember my mom was
behind you know what i mean it was one
of those things like
you had to pay i think like every time
or once a month or whatever
and like i would just go in on my own
and out and like oh my she's like did
your mom give you a check and i'm like
no i'm like oh my sister dropped me off
she's ripping out of the parking lot
meanwhile i'm like lady you think this
is the first time i've been lying about
money you're nuts
i've been pulling this my parents told
me to scam about 15 years ago
i think she sent it to the phone company
am i she's all mixed up denise is upside
down and a dumbass kid
big head
i'm looking at those egg rolls
[Laughter]
if a train leaves now give me a [ __ ]
um giving you high priority treats but
i got any rust beef
but uh i remember i was like don't cash
it till monday or whatever and i
remember being there being like you're
that's
but like that you know what that meant
at the time i was [ __ ] 17. yeah i
knew what it meant i was taking the same
been writing bad checks for years at
that point
i had to get back to the factory to work
i didn't know that you could do that and
then when i found out you could do it
well it's like a handshake deal i never
i never wrote the the the actual date i
always pushed 2028
sure it's 1999.
save this for the millennium but then
it'll be worth double
um yeah she would uh i mean but like
looking back honestly like
i've lie about
when not having money about having money
for
till about you know [ __ ] six months
ago or whatever
of ah the checking the fud the check the
thing the guy always have a hem haul and
story to you know that nobody believes
i'm sure but for my mom to be like
listen in front of me in front of those
ladies you know this woman she's just
like
and it's for the betterment of her son
of being like hey i don't have it but
here's a check wait until [ __ ] friday
that takes a lot of [ __ ]
gumption or ball you know what i mean
like you have really got to swallow your
pride in that thing
[Music]
then we got back in our sebring
convertible and [ __ ] peeled out oh
for you to get in the temple
and drink yourself with an inch of your
life hey that marking degree worked out
pretty good i assumed you had to back in
the day negotiate with uh verizon or
whoever your cell phone company was uh
you know you know if you were over if
you were late on the payment and they
got a holdi on the phone oh me
personally yes my [ __ ] got shut off
yesterday that's what i know but back in
the world
back in the day it was different you
could say i'm gonna have it in two weeks
oh they'll give you they would be like
hey we can extend it out until the 19th
if it was like the fifth or whatever and
then the second they said that
call my boys meet me at the bar let's go
kick that down the road for a couple of
weeks yeah let that breathe a little bit
that was always big like it was like
you're i forget what they used to call
like you're like it was not the honor
system but it was like good faith
payment or something oh [ __ ] well
registering as a payment promise
yeah yeah
promise payment yeah and break one of
those up wait i've been lying my whole
life
dumb give me the [ __ ] service give me
the wi-fi let's go
you're on the you're on the stand while
you're on her my fingers were crawling
you can't see my crossing my eyes the
whole time
even when they would like some some
people over the phone they would back
you
into a corner by they would say now
we're gonna record it you say yes i
agree to this at the time
oh i was committing perjury with every
[ __ ] tech company in the world
now it's one press one to authorize
payment of [ __ ] whatever whatever
well he texted him i thought it was a
two he texted me yesterday or two days
ago hey call me asap and i go to call
him back and it's like bb you've been
direct redirected to sprint online
payment system i was like ah god damn it
i thought i squared up the
uh
i have the money
[Laughter]
let's go on record kippy's got the case
he sent the check i just lose my debit
cards a lot and then it's saved on auto
pay and then like they just text you hey
you got to pay your bill but like you
know if you're [ __ ] be bopping and
scatting i'm like i'll get to it i never
get to it you make it sound like you're
a real playboy
with half a phone on eating roast beef
i was in morocco a time difference
you're like that dude who was that guy
they were hunting down that was ripping
off to the girls
no my enemies are after me yeah kinder
swindler tinder yeah i've been doing
that i've been doing that to cell phone
providers for the past decade the sprint
splinter well that was sprint but i
think t-mobile bought them but they
still treat me like the stepchild i call
sick are you a sprint i'll go into
t-mobile and they'll go are you a sprint
customer i go yeah and then they like
send you in the basement to like next to
the cobwebs go talk to igor downstairs
real [ __ ] second-class citizen [ __ ]
i'll be with you in an hour that's why
i'm a mobile man dude go sprint is a
very cell phone holster on the belt
company i'm very surprised that he uses
it it's crazy it was through uh my
family's business account
and then i left
and i was just like i just went there i
guess to keep that number because i
think you had to stay i already sent you
the free t-shirt what are you gonna do
no but
it was before you could i took the phone
case like they got me
i got a big sprint foam finger
[Laughter]
can't part with this beauty
ah [ __ ]
my dial-in wand
um
but i think at that time you couldn't go
like provider to provider i think like
to keep my number i had this is [ __ ]
you know whatever 15 years ago or
something i had to stay
in sprint if you changed your number
back then you might as well have shot
yourself in the face in a parking lot
somewhere uh-huh that was the it took
months to regain
the numbers back for people to know who
you were yeah your guy to call you back
i did it one time to free myself of it
to start fresh what yeah who would you
have heat on you no i just it was like
this liberating feeling of like i'm
[ __ ]
starting over for clean
that's why like when you get big like
we'll i'll text some of these bigger
guests that we have you know who we
become
chums with and i'll text them and then i
just get ghosted and then they text me
from a different number like a month
later like yo what are you doing i'm
like who the [ __ ] is this they stay
switching numbies i like that
i called 1-800 joe rogan nothing
he loves me
[Laughter]
i'm tony's friend
i know tony ari tammy i know everybody
talk to big hank you'll vouch for me
joey oh shout out to [ __ ] hank too
hank in austin texas good guy good man
good time down there get let's talk
about movement baby move move move move
movement do you like cool watches you
like cool sunglasses look at me i'm a
cool guy i like cool stuff get movement
and we're self-made guys aren't we let
me tell you the story about two other
guys that are self-made gentlemen two
college dropouts from southern
california wanted to turn the sunglass
industry upside down
exactly what they did now you go to the
website sunglasses watches fraction of
the price looks designer looks high-end
top quality fantastic check out movement
best thing they don't break the ban
all designed out of their california
headquarters baby shipping over a
hundred that's their hollywood 160
countries they were nice enough they
sent us two watches i got my i got my
nice would mean that when me and the
bird go out to dinner somewhere nice i
throw in a movement let them look at it
you know the only time i use it when i
want to look rich you know what i wanted
to ask you is my girl she's on the
computer i'll talk to her
i'll show her a couple of websites her
eyes get real wonky when she's doing the
computer it'd be nice if movement made
something to help the eyes when you're
on the computer all day um wait a minute
they did maybe they got their ever skull
blue light filtering glasses it's a game
changer
really helps with eye strain poor
sleeping patterns and i got good modern
styles frames
my wife uses them too okay you don't be
walking around the monocle in like a
loser if you want to elevate your look
with style that doesn't break the bank
then join movement and get 15 off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to mvmt.com
garbage one more time that's mvmt.com
garbage do it back to the show back to
the show um all right let's see here
this one we've talked about a little bit
but i don't think we've ever talked
about it this way
this is from eric
uh h-y-o-a-y-k
have you or anyone you know nice that's
what they're doing over there on a tree
on i like it uh purposely screwed up a
food order at the restaurant you work at
so you can eat the messed up food later
yeah
that's crazy we talked about um i think
people would like call it in wait you
didn't want pancakes on that burger
you sure i could have swore you said
pancake burger nothing
is it me am i crazy so you don't want
this cheesesteak omelette is that right
yeah
i meant to say cheesecake
um
that's uh that's a pro move pro move
yeah i was never really i was more of a
busboy in my my days so i didn't really
have access to the computers pro move um
real pro move um this one i never
thought about this is tommy uh is it
garbage you check the website to see
what prizes are left before buying
scratcher tickets
so now it's all public information if
you go to like
pence or new york state lotto dot com
they have how many like say you know
what whatever lucky fives lucky fives
cash for life you go they go okay
there's
i don't know i'm making this number up a
hundred thousand
lucky fives printed there's four winners
and none of them are claimed
three of them are claimed or one of them
are i think it's like you know the
patriot act or something that
who's the dirtbag lobbyist for that well
i think no it's not going into [ __ ]
that's an honest thing going in the
congress open up the books stop let's
stop letting these bozos cheat us huh
that's trashy but at the end of the day
yeah it's a smart move i feel like if
you're thinking that on that level like
that's chess not checkers [ __ ] why not
apply that to something bigger than
scratchers well you got the brains kid
you're doing you're doing the work i
think from what you told me about people
knowing the roles and this and that and
what's hot and what's not you add that
into the mix that starts to make it a
little bit more of a [ __ ] science
than than an art gives you a little bit
of an edge i think the thing of like the
tickets come out
when i used to work the at the
supermarket they had the machine and the
the running theory was when they
restocked it the winners were at the
beginning of the roll
that seemed like real
dirtbag i don't know what that was going
to be yeah i don't know what that was
based on i don't know if they were
reading that on a website sleazebag and
psychopedia yeah that was real [ __ ]
trashy but i guess maybe i don't know
if the vending guys smoking there's no
winners
go to the next seven o'clock yeah they
would get in fights and [ __ ] have you
ever used one of those vending machines
i've never used the actual vending
machine oh yeah no i like i like talking
to the guys about it and what's good
tonight
give me a titan
give me a black jack twos
i'm bound to sour skittles i've gone
from the coin star
to the scratch off that's talking about
talk about betting it all on black rags
to riches over here that's something
else
you got 40 bucks you got to reinvest
five you know
that's very much like this this is from
james uh is it garbage to go to the gas
station knowingly you're only gonna buy
five dollars worth of scratchers and
only get gas if you win
damn that's really a buddy if you're
only going to get gas if you win you
shouldn't be driving to the gas station
just waiting
for a free ticket
you're standing there trying to sell the
free ticket
75 cents
i remember that was the one of times i
remember
like we've said like families draw hard
lines in the sand of what they'll do and
what they won't do like garbage-wise
sure i mean like
and i remember i was talking to my buddy
and he was like yeah if you trade in
you're
this is back in the day when gamestop
just opened but it's like you trade in
your n64 you can get a hundred bucks or
whatever what you know
and then i'm like yeah but i want the
cash she goes yeah then just sit by the
cash register and ask people hey
give me the cash and i'll use my cred
and i'm like
that's something
my parents would disown me if i sat out
front of a [ __ ] gamestop shell and
store credit if you're lurking around
the register like a vulture yeah
jesus that's
a third-party transaction
that's real trashy man where's your
green shirt which i feel toby's i can
see toby remembering a story as we're
talking no i'm just imagining a guy
being like you want tekken i'll give it
to you 50 cents on the dollar i know
it's like that's like i'm like that's
i'm not doing all that for 50 bucks now
even then i'm like i'll [ __ ] rob
somebody okay what i was actually
thinking about was when i was on when i
had a food stamp card and running that
scam with my homies you had a food stamp
card oh yeah
jesus what are you a single mother
what the [ __ ] i was women in need i was
broke dude get a [ __ ] job you
long-haired hippie that's your people
who need it
needed it dude you couldn't find a
waiting tables job somewhere if the
government can buy missiles for syria
they could buy me a goddamn sale oh my
god that's it toby's done
but i need that meatball hoagie
i found a place to let me buy sigs with
it it's one of the only social programs
in america that works
man
how long were you on this i don't know a
couple months government assistance yeah
i was on unemployed i mean that makes
one thing what are you gonna do but
jesus yeah you were taking hand out left
and right during the pandemic not me i
was i was working hard subtitling
stand-up clips
i was taking
[Laughter]
i couldn't see global pandemic what do
you want
dude
open the clubs back up i'll do the shoes
if not cut the check we were it was put
my hours in on friday it was when [ __ ]
was getting obvious you know the [ __ ]
was getting bad in the panda and it was
me and you were doing hard feelings it
was right when we started this we're
doing hard feelings every morning
and i remember being like all right this
is gonna be longer
like [ __ ] shut down at this point and
i'm like all comedy's done i i was
working for that guy part-time he was
like kind of keeping me on her a little
bit or whatever i remember i called my
mom i'm like yo i gotta [ __ ] rent the
pet like
[ __ ] let's open up the books make
good what do we give me the rowdy number
what are we doing here
and she's like all right you're applying
for relief through your mom dude she's
like filling that an application she
goes all right you gotta press one to
agree you'll pay me back
add it to the total because you ain't
getting none of it
uh
added to that bike you bought me i said
i'd pay you back for too no she's like
she's like listen
let me talk to your stepdad she's like
i'll see what we can do i'm like all
right
so she calls me back the next i talked
to joe and
we can do 300 i'm like 300 i'm like what
the [ __ ] you might as well not even give
me anything 300.
i'm like my room was like [ __ ] 18.50
it was what turned me in i know i'm like
i'm gonna a global pandemic lady she's
like can you get a job i get a job what
the [ __ ] hiring right now
i got a job on broadway you dumb bro
what are you talking about remember yeah
i remember
what are you impulsive why don't you
just give me a [ __ ] volume and a
handgun to blow my [ __ ] brains out
she's like now i gotta turn my back on
yeah it was very it was very like we
could get that just broad gave me 300
bucks for a lifetime i know it wouldn't
even pay for the coffin
yikes yeah and then
that's when times were bad right
pod was making zero dollars zero dollars
i was staying at the shore house because
we whatever and uh now when you're
eating the old chicken from the acme
uh-huh seventy-four pack
six it was like
it was buy one get three free packs of
chicken could they kill a chicken
basketball team what the [ __ ]
the cluckers
[ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] death match
if you don't win you end up in kippy's
you end up in kippy's bait freezer
there was nothing skeevier in the
[ __ ] grocery store as a kid when your
mom would get a [ __ ] huge thing of
[ __ ] chicken parts
chicken parts is bad sometimes it'll be
legos
sounds like something you pick up with
the mechanic
hey we don't have the parts we're
waiting for them
uh we gotta order from
germany but
remember a thigh when you were a kid
you're like what the [ __ ] is that dude
now i don't [ __ ] with him get out of
here i love the good side
white meat and dark meat crispy skin
but she was like she was buying new
couches
in the chicken no my mom for the shore
she had ordered and she's like they're
coming you got to get rid of the old
couches she goes you can sell them on
craigslist and keep the money yeah i
remember that and i made 250 bucks and i
was like i'm
35 years old or whatever i wasn't he was
just looking for coconuts oh my god it
was like and then i'm like haggling with
people like you put something on
craigslist the [ __ ] worms come out
and they were like hey i can do two you
know i listed it for like 300 or
whatever it's a pull-out sofa and i love
seat you know
and uh people like i get 300 i can do
170. i can do what that and i'm like hey
i'm like how about 178 i'm like what am
i this is the worst this is
[ __ ] selling my mom's couch and
arguing over six bucks
the [ __ ] has my life come to
groan people have jobs
2781
i saw an old guy the world's worst shark
tank
for that reason i'm out you're a dirt
bag on your mom's couch and for that
reason i'm out
i saw how far we've come i saw some old
man haggling with a an uber you know
uber's set yeah so he's this guy this is
in pakistan this guy
i don't know how he [ __ ] pulled it
off but i guess he was coming from the
same place that he comes from a lot
okay
and it was usually forty dollars okay
but it was more this time and maybe i
don't know maybe it was just a cab or
something like that maybe it was a
you know sometimes uber drivers can like
randomly pick people up out in queens
it's a little fuzzy sometimes those vans
can just scoop over and pick people up
and i guess the guy was used to just
paying 40 every time and it was like
with traffic or whatever it was like 48
and this guy was [ __ ] losing it and
he didn't get it the guy's like i don't
set the it's a meter i don't know six
bucks here
he's like it's 40 every time
i'm not being cheap i just don't have it
here take the ones and he gave him like
four months and just walked the [ __ ]
away
the guy was sitting in the car like what
the [ __ ] uh-huh
so i called the cops on them
got my best guy on the case i remember
when uh i was living up town with my boy
uh
shout out to googe um
they have like those uh like the
dominican car sir uptown uptown is
predominantly dominican and my boy's
dominican and they have those dominican
car services so and which is very like
culturally haggle based you know what i
mean because there's this is before uber
and they're not they don't have meters
you know what i mean it's not like uh
yellow cabs where like you get in and
they start the [ __ ] meter is a
rooster driving
and dude they would haggle and it would
give me so much anxiety like insane
amounts i don't know it's in spanish
no no no but it's like you know and they
were they were gone just waiting for a
gun to come out oh man i'm like this is
[ __ ] tough i'll just take the bus and
then he'd be like yeah okay so we'd get
in and then we'd like open beers in the
back and i'm like what are we doing this
guy [ __ ] hates us oh it's the
own rules up there dude nice yeah get
one of those car services up there
road sodas pre uber do whatever the [ __ ]
you want in that back seat oh it's great
it's
15 people in the [ __ ] cars just hit
the henry hudson and keep going don't
look back buddy you're getting freaky
back here
drive up the palisades with the lights
off yeah
[ __ ] black light in the back
[ __ ]
it was something else
um
this one's funny this is from scott b do
you know but do you know anyone who can
rip a phone book in half get the [ __ ]
out of here
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i wrote that down
last night no [ __ ] god damn it that's a
good one
kid of the 80s that was the true sign of
masculinity
if you could [ __ ] do that there was
one guy in every town that could do it i
never met him i think a lot of dudes cut
it
on the tv shows and stuff i think that
there's for sure a trick it's a parlor
trick i'm sure
rip a little bit
yeah you started like the r's or
something yeah there's there's
definitely some let's see how to rip god
damn it i thought that was gonna kill
it did
i know but i wasn't pitching
yeah i just wrote that down yesterday
that's beautiful once you've torn
through the edge ripping the rest of the
phone book in half is relatively easy
says
yeah i don't know
but
if there wasn't a trick to it it would
be impossible i feel would it
i mean if you spent a little time in the
gym and [ __ ] drank your ag-1 maybe it
wouldn't not this week
maybe it wouldn't be yeah yeah that
doesn't make any that's it's all hand
strength too that's like do you know
anybody that could [ __ ] hang on a
telephone on a light pole sideways i
don't know anybody that can do a pull-up
man there was a kid that did a flag or
something he was frightening he was from
what they call a broken home
yeah he used to walk around with a
baseball bat no shirt on he was like 25
dating like a 13 year old it was [ __ ]
that [ __ ] happened back it was insane
there was even in my time like 2005
there was older guys like
it was a neighborhood psycho parties
misdiagnosed [ __ ] fell through the
cracks of the system they didn't know
that much back then still living at home
probably [ __ ] torturing his [ __ ]
parents it was wild yeah [ __ ] that
frightening
i think his name was ramon or something
like that paco it looked like something
from the 80s
it was the 80s oh yeah what's
[Laughter]
like something from the day we're on
uh this one's from andrew is it trash to
be so cheap that you don't replace the
broken ice machine in your fridge and
just use ice trays
that's a very ryan household thing yeah
world that's it's that option is no
longer available because no one's coming
to fix that what are you gonna uh well
like you would have to call like sears
which like we wouldn't do like my mom
does that my mom i think the
refrigerator in my parents house now
they were given a full refund for it
i think they were supposed to buy
another one with it which they did not
uh-huh just [ __ ] let that rise sure
so we're just rocking with no freezer no
freezer
what the [ __ ] you got a window unit in
there what do you mean no freezer you
don't get a freezer i'm joking the ice
machine doesn't work though okay so
there's like 15 ice trays in the [ __ ]
freezer on the bottom
dusty and stuff oh brutal [ __ ] that i
didn't start trusting those even though
it's classy i didn't really start
trusting the
uh
the door ice
ice water until relatively recent oh i
grew up we had one girl my whole that
whole time it always tasted like the the
ice cubes always have like a weird
flavor they're a little chalky or so the
you're talking about the half moon ones
yeah they were they sucked in a soda
they would kill the [ __ ] the
carbonation in a [ __ ] pepsi like that
i liked them hated it had chicken
[ __ ] chicken tender flavor ice it was
brutal and the water i just assume it
sat in the hose all day it literally
tastes like hose water like there was
like mushrooms water no no hose water
sorry it comes out every once in a while
from the suburbs of philly i don't know
what to tell you i'm [ __ ] a dirt bag
[ __ ] ed rendell over here
haze water i waited on him once
man he's an old family friend of ours he
used to sled at his house
nice uh-huh oh if i ever need a pardon
i gotta call my aunt to call him yeah he
was pretty legit nice tan [ __ ]
probably like a five thousand dollar
suit saw him had some statey with him
yeah he just sat there yeah yeah wow
real nice um he used to come
he was the governor of pennsylvania
right yeah he was the mayor philadelphia
and the governor very powerful very
powerful man he was a family friend for
a very long time still is uh but he
would come to like any time my
grandparents had like something was
something for my grandparents like their
50th wedding anniversary yeah you
weren't friends with them no it's a
family they had a big family
um he would make it a point to come and
he always came with the same
trooper yeah probably the same same guy
yeah yeah um
those guys are looking that's like one
of the trash that might remember when
you went sledding at ed's
governor rendell's house i'm like i do
not but i tell people i do hit the jump
[ __ ] 360. you start thinking i was like
i was like four or five he was praying
she didn't [ __ ] him or something like
that
denise
um
because i told you my mom had an oral
surgeon who used to park his motorcycle
in our garage
they were friends that they were friends
a lot of jokes i could have made about
an oral surgeon parking garage
motorcycle i'm not going to do it cause
i perspective
i respect your family unlike you to me
apparently but i remember at a certain
point in high school across when i was
like oh please tell me she ain't blowing
this dude or something
for garage space doesn't she watch
love you patty
she's a good kid she knows we're joking
around
she might get hot about that
refrigerator thing though that's what
she takes offense
[Laughter]
i am a [ __ ] but my ice is good
no not that about getting the money from
sears the replacement
tell anybody about that you fat [ __ ]
not replacing the refrigerator
it started working again
doing slip and falls with your fridge
you [ __ ] dirtbags
i'm gonna pretend like you got stuck in
there
i spent the night in there this thing's
possessed
there's a fat kid in my refrigerator
night at the museum the dino nuggets are
coming to life
would you go with your parents for those
kind of things like when you were
getting a new refrigerator or something
like that would you go on like a
wednesday night we moved into that house
everything was new
this was 30
three years ago nothing's changed
they're just replacing it since i've
that's not the same refrigerator you
grew up with that's the new roof that's
the new that's a new that'll be the new
fridge for the next 25 years and they'll
still call it the new fridge
that's a new fridge a new stove they
redid the kitchen
maybe
three four years there's still a couple
of things that need re done that aren't
finished that's a that's orion household
cabinets open up to outside it's 99
everything's 94
done
i used to remember that i think not even
to buy that used to be an activity like
on a wednesday night or something like
that after dinner
we'd go to like you know like a raymore
and flanagan or something like that and
they would just kind of
roll around waste some salesman's time
[ __ ] trying out recliners and doing
this and doing that
ooh i remember walking over to run i
think i mentioned this i remember
walking into a rental center with my
parents one time
and i [ __ ] was like nope not doing it
i'm not renting a couch no [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't care start working doubles i
don't care who's playing in the super
bowl
let's get the [ __ ] out of here i don't
care how great shaq says it is i'm not
renting a flight
yeah renting its microwave or whatever
let's hit friendlies and go home with a
little dignity huh yeah no we didn't buy
there was no
new
cause we did move in that house but then
that house the i mean
just started slow i remember the fridge
wouldn't close you had to lift the like
the door it fell off the hinge so you
had to lift it and like shoulder it in
for it to stick oh we had a couple of
closets like that oh yeah i mean every
every sliding door is off the track i
mean me and my brother got thrown like
he you know pushed me through it or we
were roughhousing or whatever
playing grab ass i used to [ __ ] abuse
those luon doors like what's a luon door
the thin doors that are like bedroom
doors that like it's just a hollow yeah
masonite on each side oh he used to
[ __ ] throw a punch in one of those
let everybody know
bad boy lives here
something inside but um
yeah but all the appliances that's a new
washer dry i mean they all
got 30 years out of everything and we've
never called anyone to come and fix
anything ever my mom's got people
running it out all the time no doing
this it'll be my stepdad when he gets to
it and that's about six months after it
breaks or needs fixing that's one thing
i'll give my dad i mean your stepdad was
uh is
constructionally inclined yeah
construction company yeah uh my dad he
never he knew
he would never go near a [ __ ] socket
or anything call it a guy i'm not
[ __ ] dead that's what i'm doing hey
call the fight we got the guys in the
building hey call up the [ __ ] call up
dragon and his boys and have them come
[ __ ] yeah he's a worry ward we didn't
even like changing light bulbs turn the
breaker off we used to turn the breaker
off to change light bulbs hachi machi
kill the power to the township i gotta
call the mayor he's gotta pull the plug
on the whole town there's no light in
the oven
you can't see the meatloaf cooking
it's like it's like die hard you're out
in the middle of the street talking to a
guy in a hard hat in the sewer you gotta
shut the whole block
the toilet's clogged cut the water
i don't want to flood the whole goddamn
second floor my mom comes in
and just goes through the line
[Laughter]
no siree bad
um
this one is something we've never really
uh
talked about there just from ethan
what is
the or is there a minimum amount that is
classy to go in on a gift together
my family will all pick
we'll all pitch in on a 50 gift this has
to be trash because we aren't hemmed up
wait so i guess if they're buying let's
say you let's you know let's make this
if you have to buy a present for
your uncle's
60th birthday or whatever
yeah
i mean for you probably 80th birthday
okay
um
and you're like oh we're all going to
get them
a gift and the total is 50 or 50 a piece
no we'll all pitch in on a 50 gift
that's
what is that 4.95 a piece i know it's
got i feel like it's got to be you gotta
it's got to be something big a chip in
is something big i don't even think
huge but bigger than a 50 couple hundred
dollars a couple hundred two hundred
bucks i would say is like oh we all
chipped in 200 bucks for family an ipad
yeah
what the [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] wild yeah that's bad 50
bucks i don't think i've ever done it
the the the the uh the old lady my uh my
lady will do that her and her friends
all do that for the like the girls
there's like a group of like eight of
them and it's always like it's
[ __ ] tiffany's birthday and they all
chip in they all put in 50 bucks or
whatever on whatever tiffany and get her
you know a vacation or not a vacation
but something what's tiffany's deal
single looking to me they know about me
these broads uh
probably not i don't know i don't know
if they watch the show
is there youtube in europe you tell me
youtube tell me you choose
it's called nine what they don't know
about one of the most powerful men in
podcast
i said top five five thousand
[ __ ]
um
we for christmas this year my
sister-in-law love her organized
something really nice um for my mom it
was uh it was like a package deal so it
was damn it was like um
uh
like a super deep clean from like a
really good cleaning service and then
like four regular cleans after that uh
manicure pedicure hair spa day all that
stuff and then like a lineup of uh
uh hello freshes for like two three
months that's good just to help her out
yeah yeah yeah something like i think it
was like after it was all said and done
real classy too she didn't hit me up for
until after it was all done shooting me
up in like march was like okay we got
the i didn't think you had it to be
honest with you hey i know you're a
little late on fun post ate that check
yeah um it was like 300 bucks a piece
like between like you know
me and my girl and my brother and her
whatever that's not bad that's no that's
50. come on yeah i feel yeah i would
feel like a dick eating anything at the
[ __ ] party if i knew my i contributed
four dollars to the [ __ ] gift
that that's got big mouth billy bass
written all over it too 50 bucks and he
says it doesn't he says we're not
himself so apparently they all have cash
they're just cheapskates some families
are like that
with the gifts
yeah
yeah not us we go heavy we'll go in the
debt we're not big
we're not a big on gifts i mean we've
mentioned this a lot like especially
even older now i mean like my parents of
course like the well my mom
would your mom get you for christmas
this year did you tell me probably a
[ __ ] i mean i get the same i get the
same thing every year i get like a
t-shirt a [ __ ] nike hoodie a [ __ ]
sweater
socks a couple of undies
scratchers from my stepdad built for
that sylvan learning center
yeah i wish it was so we we did not have
silvan wouldn't take a post-dated check
yeah we went to i went to some real
shampoo i was above the dry cleaners or
something
i went to some [ __ ] they they tried with
that for a minute with me but there was
no
s.a.t prep
yeah that was by then they knew this was
like ninth grade they took a shot
because i was like sitting sideways in
class they didn't know what was i don't
know what was going on couldn't find the
desk
can't tutor that um
and yeah it was some [ __ ] rinky ding
place with some bozo nerd from high
school his breath stunk i think i could
beat him up like i ain't doing this [ __ ]
dork [ __ ]
you need your words anyway dude go get
me a coffee i'm gonna be a failure till
i'm 46.
i'm not going to make a living till 50.
then i'll show you you're not even on
the jv team dork
[Laughter]
i assume neither one of you ever tutored
right what no toby
what
he was dumber than you when we took the
sat oh by the way we took the sats on
the
on the patreon way back in the day
uh yeah he was worse than you hmm
yeah i'm pretty book dumb
tudor was a good gig though if you could
do it i always wanted to be a tutor and
babysitter baby said it was a cushion
yeah that jammed up your nights you know
what i thought about friday night in
like a really rich person's house with a
couple of kids that are cool that are
going to go to sleep at a certain point
you got the big couch the big tv plus
you get the boys over
talk to the other girls on the phone
that somebody did when we were when i
when we moved up here and talked about
becoming a masseuse
because you get to set your hours
you're not in like a cubicle if you can
be and they paid like you know whatever
a hundred bucks an hour yeah you gotta
make with the happy endings
man i do strictly ladies
that'd be even maybe even worse happy
ending
why because you would probably
disappoint them
i don't think they have all right it's
been 20 minutes let's go
where's the button on this thing
they're on off switch tell your dad to
cut the power
you start jumping off
does this help you at all
i could see you in an all-white like
yeah it's a pants i thought about it
looking like a like a psych ward orderly
sure you buy the you buy the table the
fold up table well you thought about
this i mean i kicked around with those
hands
oh if i saw those things coming around
my shoulder i'd puke you kidding me and
nails hanging off there you gotta have
nice strong hands for that
okay smoking in there
no incense
incense just smells like hoagie yeah
they run incense in those places and the
nice tranquility you do it in your place
you dumb ski
ew in call you yeah
you do like two appointments a day make
150 bucks oh never what going to
somebody's house you never got a brick
and mortar i'm not going to you what
were you going to be charging for this i
mean it's through the service i think
yeah ron's jack jack
we crank it and yank it
calm down calm down and kippy's jerk hut
we make pulling weeds fun
what
you always pushing one too many times
ron's jack shacks all right get get get
that on it on the [ __ ]
what do you mean for a shirt ron's jack
jack that's pretty good somebody box
something up bronze jack jack
it's kind of like a big fist like that
who's gonna walk around with a shirt
that says jack jack on it
also it was cool to see people in the
live shows this week wearing or last
week wearing the [ __ ] bernie shirt
mm-hmm there's a kid in the front row is
the first one i saw in life i was like
oh my god there it is yeah
oh man
well these days we'll find that guy
pulling your root as a term is all right
that's a that's a me who i think i stole
from my friend who's now schizophrenic
we should start calling jizz root beer
that's pretty good tugging your fruit
tugging your root and weaseling off was
a pretty good one
[ __ ] over there weaseling off aren't
you you say pulling your pud yeah i mean
that's i'm jerking my dick
[Laughter]
uh all right let's see this we can do uh
this one and we can let's get that on
here this one a little bit of a this
isn't
he says it's a garbage but then paints a
pretty big picture it's more of a story
this is from tjb
when we would take family road trips i
would ride with my cousin's family and
every time we get hungry my uncle would
make us answer a series of trivia
questions in order to win food
question one would be for a small soda
and if we got the question question
right
we would be um
he would get then move on to a medium
soda and so forth so on and so forth if
we got the question wrong we would lose
an item
this is like jeopardy give me your shoes
uh question two for a small fry dot dot
you get the point it would get to the
point where we wouldn't even want the
food anymore and my uncle would just win
also he could be making up the answers
too [ __ ] prick sitting there with
four sodas
man eating everybody's fries and [ __ ]
it's also very trashy because i did it
exclusively if we were going somewhere
as a family like extended family if it
was us and the cousins
and the other cousins we would all the
kids would we'd want to mix and match
like oh of course like i would want to
ride with my uncle mike and my aunt
colleen and my cousin tracy cause like
they were my aunt colleen sat sideways
and it was fun and like we talked and
goofed around different car sure you
know what i mean we would always do uh
the boys and the girls because there was
my brother and sister's age the cousins
there's three boys and three girls all
the three girls the same age the three
boys are the same age
and then i was the younger
lone wolf
but so all the girls would do one car
all the boys would do the other car that
was always like you [ __ ] i'd end up
getting beat up and then one of my
cousins would hit me too hard then danny
would hit them and it was [ __ ] yeah
it backfired on me once i was getting in
a lot of trouble in 11th grade in high
school and we had to we drove down to
north carolina for my cousin's
graduation
and um uh they put me in the car with
just my uncle frank and he was supposed
to like straight it was like an
eight-hour car ride it was an old
[ __ ] it was like a late model lincoln
there was like a 50 chance i was coming
back alive i thought for sure he was
gonna pull off and [ __ ] ride out into
the desert dude i thought he was gonna
[ __ ] whack put me in a hole
yeah it was just me and him him just
crushing bernie's the whole way no radio
no nothing and then about four hours
then i heard a so what's been going on
good
i had one of those took my seatbelt off
and rolled out uh-huh i had one of those
shout out to uncle larr
put me in my
place dude it was my i'll never forget
it was my sister's graduation party and
i didn't want to go i guess it was like
if she was i was probably like 12 or 13
or whatever and i was like i want to
like hang with my friends they were all
like doing there was something big with
my friends going on
at that point like there was an event
everyone's going to [ __ ] something
i'm like [ __ ] i got this so i was like
can i go early can i go whatever my
mom's like what the [ __ ] wrong with
you you don't want to be with your
family on the [ __ ] i'm like they're
going to ah that guilt man oh later go
live with them meanwhile we were going
like a [ __ ] vfw or something i'm like
it's not like we're going to the crystal
tea room here
we're going i'm going to [ __ ] eat
meatballs out of sternos what do we do
i've done this a thousand times okay
bring me home some aju and shut it will
you i know i'll be [ __ ] trying to
make out try to grab a boob or something
let the [ __ ] kid live a little bit
trying to get my noodle wet
uh
and that was like a what the [ __ ]
and then
she didn't even tell me
my uncle larry came up he was a vietnam
vet just showed up at the house no this
was at the party oh cause it was like
i've had them come to the house
surprised on a wednesday my uncle mike's
car will just pull up in the [ __ ]
driveway and my dad was away or
something like that i knew that i was i
was [ __ ] dead yeah because you can't
yeah i couldn't maneuver with those guys
because i wasn't used to them yeah and
they were always so [ __ ] you don't
have the playbook on this they were
always
so fun and so nice but then when they
went dude well that's a that's a that's
a thing that's a thing of torture anyway
oh hey you can't be
just hey be cool easy does it
um yikes but my uncle larry came up and
he was like uh what's this i hear you
didn't want to come and i'm like yeah
that [ __ ] is lying
[ __ ] trust the word out of her mouth
uh i'm like yeah you know whatever
whatever and he goes what are you doing
this summer because it was graduation
right it was like june and i'm like he's
like
you know he joined the marines
here's a gun
uh it was like june you know he's like
june 25th you're with me and he was uh
oh [ __ ] that he was a soccer a very uh
accomplished soccer coach and he would
have camps and i had to go work the
camps
as a [ __ ] like 13 year old show you
how it is oh man and he was just like he
was one like
no zero nonsen like
i mean it was like [ __ ] you he was he
was calm and slow he didn't yell
yeah he was just looking like what the
[ __ ] is your problem
yeah my uncle mike and uncle joe were
very like that they were very calm but
then when something [ __ ] went off you
were running for the hills
he busted me making out with my high
school girlfriend in her car in the
driveway of a short [ __ ] cockblock
what are you doing
high school girlfriend what else are
they going gonna be doing what do you
think they're playing crossword puzzles
he was old-school catholic and didn't
like it at all you told me you were gay
i'd rather you be kissing dudes right
now
you're gonna knock this skank up
and ruin your life
at least timmy can't get pregnant
dude it was honestly it was something
like that he was screaming from the
porch he's like got the [ __ ] in there
right now he's like we're just talking
he's like
talking about [ __ ] you're just talking
you have lipstick
talking about killing the mood
midnight back to six
yikes all right we gotta wrap her up
gang we love you come to a live show
come see us check out that merch site
too check out that merch site we're
going to be adding uh
some shirts we're going to be adding
like a chicken sandwich shirt we're
going to be doing a lot of things just
kind of you know new fun things that
come up in the show yeah and sign up for
patreon if you don't want to know the
real scoop
who the real fellas are yeah
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace